the area in question actually just
double check I'm pretty sure the area in
question is this area yeah yeah yep okay
now this is a classic example of the
kind of area where you see how these
equations have been given to you in kind
of an awkward unusual way X is a subject
they are functions of Y okay so clearly
what they're kind of encouraging you
towards is to integrate this rather than
with respect to X with this sideways
parabola on top and the straight line
underneath they want you to integrate
with respect to Y now I think they give
you some values here I think that's four
and that's two two I think sometimes the
numbers right yeah now I just want to
caution you a little bit with this
because it might not be what you guess
okay because this is an area between two
curves it's an area between two curves I
want to form two integrals and I want
them to be you know the high one
takeaway the lower one but we're looking
at this and we're looking at it sideways
now you've got to be really careful
right think about it this way when you
look at a normal one right which is
upright and you're thinking about
everything in terms of X okay in this
case we're going to say the straight
line is above and the parabola is below
right that's because we have a clear
idea of above and below right a more
rigorous way of defining it is that
these X values sorry these Y values the
ordinates right of these numbers here
are higher greater than the ordinates
for these points along here right
because what these ones are all pretty
much positive right a lot of these ones
are negative but the ones that are
positive they're less there okay and the
sign is really critical okay because
that will help you here where as above
and below I'm not so reliable here's how
I know right when you have a look at the
parabola and the straight line which one
has higher now I'm not looking at
ordinates anymore am i I'm looking cuz
ordinates are about Y values ups and
downs okay I'm looking left and right so
which one has higher X values higher
mansu's it's the parabola right the
parabola will consistently have higher X
I'll use than the straight line does
that make sense so the way to rotate
your head and this is not that obvious
the rotate your hair ears arm is
clockwise right this is up this is off
and that makes sense because if you
think about the x axis right Yukons
you're in the new your 1 2 3 4 etc I'm
actually sorry that should be 2 you get
the idea no is it going up that way
ok so therefore this is the critical
part the numbers itself take care of
themselves but when you're forming the
integral for that area right you form
and I'll make sure that make a mention
of a couple of things here you form the
integral from your Y boundaries so
there's the lower one and there's the
upper one I'm going up okay you've got
your parabola as it were on top that's
your higher function ok so I'm going to
go 5 Y minus y squared minus 4 and then
I subtract the lower function one with
smaller X values which is 4 minus one
that's all with respect to Y ok is that
alright so this you can see is going to
simplify just a little bit what do we
got here I'm gonna put it in in order of
the power so that means my a negative Y
squared should be out the front how many
Y is doing 1/2 cy6 why cuz find y double
negative so becomes 6 minus 4 minus 4
minus 8 watch out for that one that's an
easy error to make and then you can go
ahead and find the primitive from there
okay now just a little note I'm gonna
skip some of the working because I think
you know what to do from here when you
get down to an answer I'm gonna mention
this is something I've been actually
honestly a little bit sloppy with PI Lee
because it doesn't matter if you were
that sloppy but if you want to be really
correct
you notice all the way through right
I've been just dealing with numbers
there are no units here ok the answer I
get at the end is one on the third okay
now so far I've been doing sort of a
quick and dirty way which most people
have also been doing and say once you
get to the end you say okay now I have
units all right now technically speaking
that's not correct because they were
never units up here right - why should
units a wild unit square
something appeared you really shouldn't
do that the best way the most like
correct way to do this is to say this is
some number it's just a number that's
all ready to go tell you and then you
make a conclusion you say okay the area
is this thing and that's where the units
appear okay now this is kind of more
important as we start looking other
things for instance using integration to
work out things that aren't areas we
just have to wait till the next couple
lessons to find out what those are okay
but like I said I don't think you would
ever lose marks for saying units squared
he which is pot pot wine I've been a bit
lazy there but if you want to do it
exactly properly there are no units all
the way through it's just a number and
then you make a concluding statement
okay so like I said be careful when
you're integrating with respect to Y
because op is not as intuitive as it is
when you're integrating with respect to
X but after you've done that everything
is exactly the same I mean you know some
of the lines are skipped the primitive
is gonna read exactly the same minus y
cubed on three plus 3y squared right cuz
you're divided by two minus 8y and
you're gonna go from two to four etc
okay so I just wanted to point that out
because people often get the inspiration
with respect to Y they often get it
wrong because they rotate their heads
the wrong way just watch out for